so first of all tell us a little bit
about these letters that you've sent to
the two leadership candidates what are
you saying in that letter
well we've sent a letter to both the
candidates just saying that my members
are really concerned about uh summer
which is a bit like winter we've got
winter we've got we've got winter in
summer we have three challenges that are
pretty fundamental we have a Workforce
challenge a hundred thousand vacancies
in the NHS 165 000 in Social care we
have an estate challenge with crumbling
buildings and very old equipment and we
have a social care challenge again in
that we're not recruiting or paying
enough staff to get people out of
hospital or impossible which is meaning
we've got a backlog of ambulances
working in a e and we can't move people
into hospitals because we can't move
them out of hospitals because we don't
have social care packages for people
once they when once they're well well
enough to leave hospital so in some
cases we've got 20 of feds taken up with
people who could leave but can't leave
because there's no social care packages
we have a backlog in elective care which
my colleagues are working really hard to
reduce and in fact I'm making some
inroads even though it's increasing but
the the state of the buildings means
they can't I mean they can't carry out
the operations and we certainly have
long Capers where where the roof in the
hospital is causing real problems for
use of elective care surgery and as I
say we have a problem with vacancies now
neither candidate has addressed these
issues full-on
um and we need them to be evolved
because if we don't
um we can't offer the the care that
people deserve and they pay for in their
taxes so we have a real problem on top
of that we have an inflation challenge
which is wiped out the very welcome
additional funds that were given to the
NHS earlier so what we need from both
candidates in some when even to level
with the public basically about what is
going on what what the public can expect
and what they're going to do about these
short-term actually medium term and
long-term prices in the NH effects and
social care system
and what do you want to hear from them
apart from addressing the issue more is
it more money that you're after
well I'd like I'd like them first
acknowledge that there is a crisis that
this is really serious nine out of ten
of our leaders are basically saying that
this is this is the worst I've seen it
and it's and it's going to continue I
think you know it's not for me to tell
them how to manage the economy but I do
think we need to be honest with with uh
with taxpayers about the fact that you
get what you pay for at the end of the
day and you do we do need a health
system which which actually is a
contributor to the economy if you're
working for an operation on your hip
your knee your cancer treatment you're
not working if you're not working when
you're not contributing to the economy
you're not paying taxes so this is a
significant challenge for the economy a
helping nation is a working Nation if
we're not healthy then we can't work so
what we need is both candidates to be
straight with people about the state of
being their checks in the healthcare
system and actually put forward credible
ways in which we can resolve the matter
in the medium something long term
the the National Insurance rise which
has been debated a great deal in this
leadership a contest
was destined it was money the money that
was raised was destined for the NHS now
Rishi sunak is going to keep that rise
Liz truss has said that the country
can't afford it the people can't afford
it the the cost of living crisis is too
great for people to pay extra taxes
what's your take on that
well I can tell you what we can't afford
we can't afford an NHS system which is
crumbling and can't treat people
properly so they can't work so we
welcome the additional funds and we
would want that to continue
um it's for the two candidates whoever
becomes prime minister to make the
difficult choices that's why we have
prime ministers on our behalf to ensure
that the NHS and social care system is
properly funded but what we do need is
is realism we need them to be real
realistic with the public it's not about
political Retreat or gimmicks it's about
saying to the public this is the state
of the NHS and social care system this
is what we're going to have to do yet to
be anybody certainly
um in the Care Health or care system
who's saying you know I'd rather have a
lower tax and mental health system I
think I think that's not a credible
choice and I I we look for our leaders
to present us with solutions to these
challenges it's my job to perform and be
with the real estate of the NHS and the
healthcare system will be talk on my
members well yes and if we look at the
different candidates Liz truss has said
that she will provide the funds
necessary she'll just raise them through
a different means and she's talked about
measures like stripping away certain
levels of management as well what do you
make of the plans that she's announced
so far as far as the NHS is concerned I
don't I don't know that they're very
specific or clear and I'm not sure that
they addressed the challenge you know
the the issue here as I've said is that
we have 165 000 vacancies in Social care
we have a hundred thousand vacancies in
the NHS we need a fully custom Workforce
plan which actually ensures that we can
employ enough people to care for your
relatives my relatives and members of
our community they need to be very clear
about how they're going to fund that
they need to be clear about what
resources they're going to make
available to fix our crumbling estate
and on our equipment and the need to
ensure that we prepare social care
workers so good enough so that we can
find the packages of care that get but
get people into hospital we can get
people out of hospital so we get
desperate people in need of urgent care
in basketball so I'd like specific
answers to those three key questions
um one of which we need to be resolved
now I mean the social care challenge
we're simply not paid social care
workers enough to do the skill job
necessary to get people out of hospital
and so that we can actually get
ambulance people in the back of
ambulances these aren't people who are
who are Delux fantasy people in
desperate need of emergency care in
hospital and and who have to work in the
back of ambulances sometimes for hours
if you get an ambulance at all because
the ambulances are rushed to the end of
the rush to the end of their capacity so
we need answers to those specific issues
that's why we've been so clear in the
letters of both candidates and and could
those answers be provided by a special
task force because that's where she
sunak's plan isn't it to introduce the
task force along the lines of of the
covered vaccine task force to try and
address some of these issues you welcome
that well I'm all I'm all for task
forces and um um specific interventions
but again they avoid be avoid the answer
you know we know what the answer is to
the social care problem we've said we we
as a as a membership body don't don't
complain without presenting Solutions
the answer to the social care challenge
is to pay people a minimum of 10 pound
for 50 an hour that means we can
actually attract people into social care
or keep people in Social care who are
leaving to get easier jobs in say a
refill
um
we know that the backlog in capital
building requirement just requires an
injection of cap of money and we know
that the inflationary costs that are
reduced actually reduced the amount of
money available to the NHS needs an
urgent injection of cash to put that
right we can do the rest I have full
confidence in my colleagues in their
leadership abilities and in the front
line of our NHS and social care system
to deliver as they did during the
pandemic what they need is the resources
and the leadership to enable them to do
so so you know I think I think what we
need is specific response is that I'm
all I will work with whoever my members
will work with whoever becomes prime
minister but what we need them to be to
be doing is to be really honest about
you know these are the challenges we
accept what we're saying as leaders of
the Health and Social care system this
is what we're going to do with you with
with you to resolve them and we've made
suggestions we're very clear about what
needs to happen